mit ihrem einsatz bewegen mehr kultur
swisslos wünscht ihnen viel vergnügen
die wechseljahre der frau fluch oder
segen
körperliche veränderungen dazu die angst
vor dem unsichtbar betten in der
gesellschaft aber auch in der kultur
klar doch frauen erkennen heute die
möglichkeiten des neuen lebensabschnitts
nach den wechseljahren bist du eine
bessere version von mir selbst jede wahl
ist sondern ein taxi da wird energie
frei nutzen
eine bestandesaufnahme zu risiken und
nebenwirkungen der wechseljahre aber
ganz besonders zu den chancen
[Musik]
sie kommen auf den kulturplatz ja kaum
eine phase im leben einer frau ist mit
so vielen negativen klischees besetzt
wie die wechseljahre
damit wollen wir aufräumen denn diese
zeit im leben einer frau kann eine große
positive verwandlung sein privat wie
beruflich und darüber spreche ich gleich
mit der schauspielerin barbara terporten
hier im zürcher hotel kreuz
stöhr ist auch
gutes vollbracht wie granit äußerung
frage ich dich jetzt das frei raus die
wichtigste fotos an dick wie alt bist um
7.40
mit 512 gesellschaft vor jetzt haben wir
das schon mal transparent gemacht ja
beantworten kann einmal als
bühnenschauspielerin aus
filmschauspielerin und osttirol vom
bestatter
du weißt es die schönste niederlage
aber die damit auch wieder in allen
zusammen
er schätzt sc
herford versucht
ihre gemeinsame
jugend sind
rum bis dahin so kriegst du ja so gut
stipe
ich muss erst ende august
[Musik]
was meinst du die rolle jetzt nur über
mit 740 war sie nach nehme aber viele
stoffe ist mir einfach nicht so gut
könnte 6
li zusammen aber man schaffe ja
alpha tonnen so gut
gibt es einen plan b wenn man weiß dass
ich irgendwann vorbei ja das hat nicht
gemacht ich habe gewusst das wird
schwierig diese große rolle ist sie die
werde mich nicht wieder besetzen und ich
habe mir stand bei als regisseurin
aufbaut im theater allerdings klug
[Musik]
eine andere stelle bis 10
ja auch offen set ist fotograf im median
klug sie hat jetzt gefordert herford und
inszeniert oder genau das ist kein ist
für das kursbild das mitglied abholt und
sonst nicht möglich schwul ist und sie
sich dass jene vergessen dass sie
fotografiert ganz viel staatliche bilder
von starken frauen hat vor ihnen ein
buch das neue 40 alles kann nichts muss
wirklich versammlung vor starken frauen
sie haben sie alle fotografiert was ist
statement von der burg sich das buch
ihre frage von viel erreicht und mit
tränen sind vor ort aufzeigen ob jetzt
die sich selbst hosen sind viele toll
ist auch passieren
der fotografie das frauenbild ist immer
auch hier ist als abziehbilder oder als
klischee des bildes hat viel mit
sexismus so wie schaffen wir da wirklich
einen schritt weiter zu engagieren
mit jedem doch weg im zweifelsfalle
möglichst nicht kritisieren also ich
persönlich den falten und bis wahnsinnig
schön und ich bin voll im gegensatz zu
jugendlichen schönheit ist komplett
anders und ich finde das muss man nicht
vergleichen und nicht genannt so spiele
sondern sich
das ja
unbedingt
als junge frau oder soll die frau bitte
sexy sein aus mutter voller liebe und
fürsorglichkeit und dann mit den
wechseljahren haben sie unsichtbar
werden soweit die klischees von
vorgestern und wie ist es wirklich hier
unser stand der dinge
[Musik]
das wirklich zu hause in blüte tvo mit
mini mini zieht und jede wahl ist
sondern ein taxi da wird energie frei so
da ist als eine zeit des umbruchs die
wahnsinnig schwierig ist und so war das
bei mir auch und es war die fuß und ich
wusste nicht mehr wo oben und unten ist
[Musik]
die aufgriffe befasst sich mit der salbe
mit den körper
[Musik]
wenn es einem schlecht geht körperlich
jede frau erlebt die jahre vor und nach
der menopause individuell
schriftstellerin milena moser
journalistin silke buhrmester
psychologin pascalina peric und
gynäkologin china delhis sind sich aber
in einem punkt einig wir müssen über das
klimakterium reden viel zu lange wurde
der rapide hormon abbau bei der frau
tabuisiert
aus scham unwissenheit wegen
gesellschaftlicher normen erziehung
religion viele haben angst nicht mehr
begehrenswert zu sein da wird los
während in anderen kulturen frauen mit
den wechseljahren aufgewertet werden
also die dann auf einmal reif sind für
ich sag mal so was wie den ältestenrat
diedorf führung oder was auch immer
findet bei uns eben eine entwertung
stadt deshalb partiell geborenes der vor
acht monaten palais flux ins leben
gerufen eine online plattform auf der
frauen ab 47 sich kreativ einbringen
texte verfassen und austauschen können
es ist eine form von selbstermächtigung
und dieser gedanke zu sagen okay wenn
die gesellschaft den scheinwerfer nicht
mehr offen richtige tun wir es eben
selbst ist genau das das ist das was ich
brauche damit ich mir das gefühl also
ich komme aus der opferrolle heraus ich
muss da nicht denken oder die anderen
die sind jetzt sie wollen dich nicht
mehr sehen sondern ich denke wir machen
deshalb selbst und das ist gut die
wechseljahre sind in aller munde dank
emanzipation mehr selbstbewusstsein und
der aussicht auf ein langes leben sind
frauen bereit intimes zuteil vor zehn
jahren beginnen milena moser mit sibylle
aeberli noch fast tabubruch
[Musik]
[Applaus]
b
im zuge der wechseljahre der heißen
jahre wagte moser einen radikalen
neustart sie wanderte in die usa aus wo
sie sich mit 51 unsterblich verliebte in
die schweiz reist sie nur wenn sie das
will
in ihr drin
der ganz klaren kompass stimmt das für
mich kann ich das will ich das kann ich
nur
wenn ich traue mir so viel mehr zu ich
mache mir experiment ich probiere ich
viel rum
zu den mittleren lebensjahren hat die
psychologin pascalina peric geforscht
auch für sie ist klar die wechseljahre
sollten als entwicklungsphase
wahrgenommen werden noch neudefinierung
und neupositionierung stehen an
als entwickler von der eigenen stand
jetzt von der lg
dimension in der mitte jahr für gas aber
nicht dass die ersten hälfte ganz stark
dominiert ist vom gedanken sich in der
gesellschaft vor ort einer gesellschaft
erzieht und
und seien in london's medikament ist
frage ist ja wo bin ich selbst lebe das
ist das was ich den
mut machen will dass du im prinzip nach
den wechseljahren bist du eine bessere
version von mir selbst
damit der weg dahin nicht qualvoll wird
seit die gynäkologin himmel und hölle in
bewegung der nebst wallungen kann das
klimakterium auch chronische
schlaflosigkeit bis hin zu depressionen
bedeuten
sila delhis empfiehlt jeder frau den
hormon abbau auszugleichen auf einem
niedrigen niveau
mit ihrem buch women on fire löst sie
eine hitzige debatte aus
also montag hätten heisst ja gibt in dem
bewusstsein vieler menschen und das soll
man ja nicht machen und wäre das nimmt
es ja irgendwie schwach nur der held ja
nix aus der ist der kapituliert
sozusagen für den wechseljahren aber das
ist das so ist falsch diese vorstellung
ist falsch es ist es ist nicht nur
unnötig so sehr zu leiden ist es sogar
ungesund also man weiß diese hormon
defizit bereitet wirklich den boden für
ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
alterskrankheiten vor und mittlerweile
nimmt man körper identische hormone das
sind
hormone die exakte exakte kopien sind
von dem was der körper früher
hergestellt hat und deswegen ist ja
nicht für den körper nicht belastbar
oder belasten
ich finde es ein bisschen schwierig denn
wir reden über einen natürlichen prozess
nun leben wir in einer gesellschaft die
sich immer mehr von natürlichen
prozessen entfernt ist ist so es ist so
vorgesehen es hat seinen sinn und meine
aufgabe ist damit klar zu kommen am
tumor ist natürlich tumor ist natur ja
schlangenbiss in natur und 19 ist
naturnah also alles ist natur aber ein
tourist nicht unbedingt gut david ist
ein fürchterlicher krankheit diabetes
ist eine fürchterliche franke aber
wachsen sind teil von
referenten kopf wird zum reflex wieder
mit de
würden sie ausgleichen oder wenn sie zum
arzt gehen würde wenn sie blut abnehmen
und sagen oh ich hab mich mit vitamin d
ich nehme mir jetzt wieder mandy immer
ein vitamin d-spiegel anzuheben und so
macht man das mit den hormonen auch
studie
problem
mit der körperlichen umstellung der
dritten liga deshalb spezielle und gar
nicht wüsste ich nicht wie so dass man
denn all die frau was der kamm schere
und
medikamentös behandelt es gibt
tatsächlich ein drittel der frauen die
sagen ich habe keine hitzewallungen aber
was haben sie denn noch haben sie
gelenkschmerzen sagen ja aber ich glaube
ich habe irgendwie römer und die mutter
und der vater auch und aber was ganz
viele nicht wissen tatsächlich 25
prozent der frauen haben gelenkschmerzen
als einziges symptom in den
wechseljahren also die meisten frauen
die sagen sie haben nichts haben doch
irgendwas wenn man lange nur fragt ein
rückschritt in
die wechseljahre medico leasing oder
praktisch nur medikalisierung ich sag ja
auch nicht mein weg ist der königsweg
für alle sowie geht es darum frauen auch
zu klären damit sie einfach wissen dass
die optionen haben
aufklärung kommunikation
selbstbestimmung die gebote der stunde
ein bewusster umgang mit den
wechseljahren wirkt die chance der
persönlichkeits findung und damit neue
perspektiven für die gesellschaft
[Musik]
dass man neue vorbilder schafft war nach
für die nachfolgende generation also ich
nicht sehr hilfreich sind
na dann willkommen wechseljahre
[Musik]
na wie geht's denn die ideen oder
fordern viel beschworene wachse ja ich
überhaupt schon drin tja wenn ihr das
willst
also mir geht's gut wirklich sehr gut
ich auch energie aber ich mag es so dass
mir natürlich und ungeschickt gemacht
wurde wenn du mal mussten ist der be und
wie hast du dir vorstellen dass es
weitergeht was man macht sich also
gewisse gedanken bin ich bereits um
grundsätzliche frage wo ich zuvor
beschäftig bevor meist hitzewelle über
man sah man sie überhaupt sind ja
klischee sehen auch beim ich glaube dass
ich habe bisher individuell sind das 12
monats verurteilt muss glaubt jede frau
für sich zu finden das muss sowieso
jeder mensch finde was für gesunde und
gute ideen vermissen über sport über
alles und dir hinterfragen diese schon
viel früher scharfe oder was tut mir gut
aber ich würde wahrscheinlich bis machen
wenn ich merken es nicht zu wirklich in
mir depression und wird lourdes dass das
wieder gut geht so ja dann ist das
sicher legitim oder wenn man sich hilft
nimmt
sondern
die frage wo subtile die frau wohl nie
kreisstelle und ihre zweitstimme kann
ich habe es erlebt und wenn man ein
problem hat dann gilt also plötzlich
sucht frau oder was das natürlichste
gewalt wieso hast du das nicht und und
somit um jetzt jetzt andere erlaubt und
die finde das ist eine verurteilung geht
das ist ganz wichtig und spreche ich
ihnen einen wert mit anderen frauen
darüber geredet wenn man von außen mit
hilfe geholt und je mehr miteinander zu
tun hat und frau solidarisch miteinander
reden wie ist spd und wie man auch
studios unter hsv mal ausprobieren um so
einfach und man viele studie zieht also
ich erlebt dass auch dass man unter
freunden wirklich hat repariert ist das
richtig und kraß folgen und das darf man
nicht verurteilt und darum sehr wichtig
was man für die holz- oder also wie es
mittags sie was hätte gemacht gericht
ist eine ode an war man sich schützt
oder die was hast du für oder im wallis
ja als hat eine sieht natürlich
minimiert andererseits bin ich schon
nach ostern schule was nun erkannt die
kapazität zum studieren ich spannende
sachen küste über philosophie
psychologie
ja das ist
das absolute role models sie aber aber
doch eher richtig spaß ist an kunden mit
50 genauso sache war schon krass machen
kann und natürlich wohin welche nicht
absehen oder so nicht trocken da ja
diese volz mit dem blut muss allerdings
zu der generation und sage dass die
natürlich mit zu unterstützen vor einem
mann wie mir hört das ist modern mord
und hilft mit und und das schiff familie
wird zusammen geführt
hoffentlich in vielen fall und das ist
natürlich ja das ist entlastend oder
jetzt bist du immer brav und alters die
ob ihnen wo sie nichts um das haus
schließlich macht mit ihrer vita über
das rathaus herrscht haben aber noch
zwei andere berufskollegen vor der
pubertät orten wo man zu dem thema
befragt hat
rachel braunschweig 53 jahre alt
schauspielerin aus zürich wo sie auch
heute mit ihrer familie lebt
arian andere ecken 52 jahre alt
schauspielerin wohnhaft in basel und
hamburg
zwei frauen die gegen die sogenannte
alters klotener spieler rache
braunschweig im film marian andere ecken
im theater sie ist über 50 sie ist eine
frau und sie hat einen beruf der
älterwerden nicht verzeihen
age on stage nimmt sich andere in ihrer
eigenen biografie an auch im hinblick
aufs altwerden als schauspielerin
der darstellbarkeit
hier verschwinden schauspielerinnen bei
bestem wetter
die künstlerinnen
das ist ein business denkt stück
extrem so gedanken um ein thema wo
gedanke drin vorkommen und kritik ist
natürlich eindeutig dass er frau
zwischen 40 oder ende vierzig bis
sechzig verschwinden
marian andere kennt versteht es ihre
themen auf die bühne zu bringen und
verschafft sich durch ihren
intelligenten witz gehört theater machen
unbesehen zu wird
also wenn es so langsam gott erstens
viele
kollegin deformiert wurde ich trenne im
alter die handys gehört der artus mache
mit ganz merkwürdige ängste
und ihre kunden da machen nötig wird
krank also ich mache
angst frage wo die sie und ich kann dich
wahnsinnig süß wie wenn man älter ist
muss man doppelt so gut sie wenn man
unsere unterschicht und wie ich muss man
auch noch mal dazu kurz muss als frau
muss man aber zu kurz das macht drei mal
doppelt das muss man 12 uhr wird sie
zwölf mal besser sein oder
verschwinden
rachel braunschweig denkt nicht daran
sich verschwinden zu lassen
passiert stattdessen lieber zum
shooting-star für ältere männer normal
für frauen die ausnahme
und sicher auch filme von der
gesellschaft und und verwertet alt hat
andere entscheide ich bin da
im alter und die geschichte wohl ich
verkörpere sind erzählenswert und es
gibt es gute gründe für
seit wenigen jahren steht sie als
schauspielerin hoch im kurs in
publikumsrennern die die göttliche
ordnung und ein perfektes wieder
wolkenbruchs wunderliche weise
als katharina von zimmern in zwingli
oder als staatsanwältin im schweizer
tatort
sind
im aktuellen kinofilm spagat hat
braunschweig ihre erste hauptrolle
lehrerin marina lebt zufrieden mit
ehemann und tochter auf dem 8 dennoch
unterhält sie eine liaison mit dem vater
einer ihrer schülerinnen besonders
heikel der ukraine lebt ohne papiere in
der schweiz
[Musik]
spiele brach in braunschweig spielt die
marina eindringlich glaubhaft und damit
alle gegen die wand das drehbuch
schrieben zwei junge männer mitte
dreißig einer von ihnen führte regie
ich möchte zum wettkampf zu spezialisten
jörg
unsichtbarkeit sieht anders aus und zu
alt gilt für rache braunschweig nicht
ich bin da
ich bin voller energie ich bin voller
lieder schafft filme für mich
die hälfte und raus bist viel hätte
jetzt noch mal so richtig russ bronze
brachte braunschweig erzählt mit ihren
rollen geschichten die für alle
generationen und alle geschlechter
spannend sind und das will sie auch
weiterhin
marian andere ecken geht nicht den weg
des mainstreams und hat denn sehr viele
menschen einiges mitzuteilen sichtbar
und laut
beide frauen sind veritable index keine
späten sondern großartige die ihrem weg
in der zweiten hälfte des lebens gehen
und fahrer werden in
[Musik]
bezug auf alter das merkt man natürlich
schon
so viel im film er die facc pille danach
will krupp aber es ist lang sie ich hab
ihn ändert sich jetzt langsam ich bin
gegangen das beispiel von der
schwedische serie wurden staatsanwalt in
hat seinen grauen haare satz kommt denn
blondiert die haut was sagt mir dass
über die leute die nichts mit dem land
jetzt verschiedene am morgen kind und
nach schaffte irischer fall wichtig die
jetzt geht sie zum haus fahren und das
finde ich total spannend was mancher
user du engagierst dich sehr faire
bedingungen für frauen im schauspiel mit
dem verein viel elektronik gründet hat
ist das noch immer als kampf gegen
klischees oder
vielleicht wirklich ständig und
diversität auf der bühne und im film und
natürlich vertonen und jetzt bei mir bin
im falschen
kann man sagen natürlich ein gewisses
mischte und was heißt dass wir das
ältere system an anfield road ist zu alt
ist die wirklichen nur die motor- oder
dass ich schon immer wie
vertrag gefragt wurde wo ich gar nicht
ob sie alleine oder mit seinem motiviert
aber das dann wiederum mit zelt will den
teenager
schwangerschaft aber wir zählen das
nicht also das sind dann so bilder wo
man vermittelt weil wachower zuschauerin
überhaupt nicht cool sind wenn man so
eine junge mutter und jetzt schon eine
20 jährige tochter war aus überwiegend
aus mit links haben das sind einfach
eine coole geschichte und sich
aufeinander ohne cool wenn sie ja das
ist dann gleich so gut
dass dann sei es nun die rollen oder
wenn das stimmt nicht mit mir mit meiner
überzügen oder mit dem frauenbild über
ihn ja das stimmt ihr euch letzten
wahlkampf keine rolle das ist ein
theaterstück sieht die autorin unbedingt
wurde das ist eben ein kriegsgebiet
und wie so was ist so schlimm daran dass
ich okay jetzt kann ich sagen 44 oder so
was ist so schlimm daran und das war für
mich ein grund richtig zum stritten und
aussagen auf der bühne und ich muss das
für körper und ich wollte nicht so ich
meine spiele wenn ich jetzt mit wird der
55-jährige spieler mit 47 sie schon in
realität und wir sind zur sache wo man
da nicht auf erzählt mein licht auf und
die realität sieht nach viel spannender
und anders und aber treibe ich erwartet
denn dadurch noch spannender und man die
männliche rolle dürfen und welche es ist
nicht das man sei jetzt mehr und geht
weg und so sondern es ist es zusammen
wie sie gesellschaft besteht 15
[Musik]
zu diesem thema gebe ich ihnen gern noch
einen persönlichen tipp mit auf den weg
die weisheit der wechseljahre von der
amerikanischen ärzten christian in
nortrup ist für mich ein symbol dafür
dass wir diese lebensphase wirklich auch
aus große chance verstehen können
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen ihr kultur
streams
[Musik]